the two topics that we've done they
break their codes I might forget what
the code birth two letters in another
one that's two topics that we just did
we just did at that one financial mess
well before that
hey everyone right what is it if Stan
algebraic manipulation is the fancy name
okay that's m1 right we're about 2 a.m.
2 a.m. - yeah it's a bit weird
it's called linear relationships which
doesn't sound like it has much to do
with algebra except no one it does and
number two one of the main things that
was uh a real thing through that
interesting feedback they don't tell you
about or is that the thing that Weston
struggle with in general is algebra
right algebra is high algebra is kind of
like a read game where the rules are
just nonsensical you're trying to
memorize how it works and I know if you
interview who played that game it's a
card game called mouth before it's a
collie game with literally you have the
area cards which is a normal kind of
doll for game but there's one person
who's like the cod the dealer and he
makes up rules he makes up rules and you
don't know what the rules are when you
break them you just get give an extra
card you're like why do you think your
cards and then one of the typical rules
is if you ask why you got your heart so
just get it so it's a it's a depressing
game to playing and also it can be a bit
like that's why
we're going to waiting to play me
because it's very particular thing have
like a cool deal on he's just gonna
y'all say about what kind of deal are
they anyway we hope you can technically
should open up down the chat with yeah
it's chapter well you're like wait step
3
chapter 1 chapter 12 we go right to the
end because it's the right thing to deal
with early on so we get those categories
of mine so all the way through we can
ask a few questions on there and really
sort of master that skill so that's why
we're going to look at exercise to obey
today alright time to destroy but not
already I'd like you to open up to that
so I want to give you firstly there's
three main ideas that we're going to
look at here so I'm gonna give you a
very brief overview of the topic that's
a reading question the page I've got is
403 may be back now MA
so we ran into and underneath your hey
Kiki off you crap I want you to write
three dot points now when we're doing a
one we're focusing just on the letters
and numbers just um the pretty invisible
rearranging it's solving so okay we're
kind of gonna make a bit of a step and
think about the visuals like what does
it look like what does you've seen
something like this when I see that when
I write that I have a picture in my head
maybe you'd have a picture too depending
on how much you got to do every nine ten
raise your hand
yeah well that's what this song is about
I'll show you what the picture looks
like
that's the picture in my head and you're
like where'd that come from will by the
end of this topic Union we're so the
three topics the three skills that
you're going to learn which will show
you how to get from that to that
ah number one okay so the first the
first paid skill on - under linear
relationships is like these things
crashed right which is short for
graphical representation these graphs we
want to be able to ignore them and also
really get interpret them
okay like once you've got one in front
of him what does it mean versus how can
you make it work okay so that's what
these two skills yes sorry um the second
thing is what we call modeling now one
of the reasons why many relationships
are so important is because heaps of
things in the world are linear
relationships that means you've got
choose things two quantities and they
grow or they shrink and they grow or
shoot together in what we call a linear
way right it's kind of like the event at
the same rate just like if you go too
long
what's an example okay depending on the
place you go two by threes right
some places W cheese counts as we get
you know larger documents and other
places like forget it like if you bought
50 of these I'm still gonna start to the
same right jerks but that car thing that
growth rate is a linear relationship
they're growing at the same rate
together so we are going to model
different situations things like money
but yet
using this kind of
okay the last major skill last major
skill does this sound like is that
related hands up how many of you
remember simultaneous equations okay
hands down I won't ask how many of you
mastered it because I suspect that might
be a bit of a depressive personality um
what this has to do with this is in fact
this drawing that I just gave to you
right 2x minus 5 there's a picture that
goes behind that and 3 there's a picture
it goes behind that so many
simultaneously is just where do these
happen at the same time where is that
spot right what's that value that's what
it means right that's just what it
represents so we're really going to boss
that unfortunately you know today kind
of just braces by you don't get the time
so get into it